hello and welcome to this video playing
at stun eat off I lost some very stupid
game against this guy recently I don't
remember what exactly it was it's no I
remember I i blundered something pretty
horribly there and that exchange that i
that i blundered ok let's see and line
him oh it's like gently i think that
black is completely ok quindi three
especially ok that's a very rare line
what is going for a pawn sacrifice ok um
I wonder if I take on bitoni or let him
take I think i'm taking my team myself
yeah this kind of porn sacrifices they
are quite often at least them correct in
a practical game because white has lots
of lots of activity they have to be
alerted this is one of those people you
just place move move move move move and
doesn't care much about the quality of
the moose so i have to watch the time
well now is taking some time actually
surprisingly
yeah white compensation is in isn't
other active pieces push-ups on great
great spots k Bishop f6 probably not
mmm okay d 6 would return upon b6 as
well yeah okay he has pressure that's
absolutely clear I can go F 6 million I
mean f6 if he trades that should help
and if he goes back well we'll see about
that maybe just be six ok he takes it it
doesn't feel so threatening if five he
just has a check on c4 it's not more
than a check
okay out for 23 something like that hmm
I don't have a good square for that
Bishop
and a five is a bit dicey then I
probably have to probably have to that
is God roop t6 coming
and this might return a poem but yeah I
saw that but wasn't sure if I can can
avoid this kind of thing
the worst part is that he is attacking
b7 and he might just take it
they might just taken going for work 25
in that case
so I wanted to go at four I'm just not
sure that I can yeah okay let's put this
on a safe square first and then see what
happens KF 4 okay it can actually take
it because of the the back rank I guess
okay when I'm controlling the dark
squares here so i'm not sure that can do
something here of course immediately so
this is not working he has figured that
all out in a second and probably has he
indeed has well its got queen of three
now I can go G for now I mean I'm not
really threatening on g3 so even that is
debatable if he should go g4 but looks
kind of normal
probably going to f6 next to threaten on
g3 if he I mean g4 I'm still thinking he
would do that but
takes very long time now
it's not disconnected
and why do you have to think a minute
here I didn't ever get the kind of thing
maybe this just something else happening
at this place
time morning I don't threaten much yeah
I'm just being annoying here I don't
know when I should have stayed on h4
keep that and pressure there
check
check so I'm a piece up for some reason
check check I know I don't chat what
happened here maybe had some something
disturbing happening at home on with
this long time strand check check check
white for Vince on time I know that was
weird game yeah he had definite
compensation all of this opening but
it's definitely clear ok this is that it
was all kind of normal and have six I
expected him to not take that that feels
wrong but you still had pressure somehow
check not easy it's not easy at all to
play the engine goes g6 in this position
then and then Bishop d7 now I need a
couple of moves again if I get in we
should be Sam Luke 28 bishop CA door so
I can think of trying to convert a porn
but 96 didn't occur to me I saw that
this is possible but I thought that I
would be activated what I didn't see so
much is that Bassam Hanks so I am I gave
him that porn
as you get that Bishop on the active
diagonal yeah this kind of decision I
always amazed well III is good probably
a queen age form and I'm in huge danger
here and I think here I should have some
chances because of that pressure on f2
the engine just gives Y declared winner
but I'm not completely convinced
I canceled the difficult would like to
just do nothing here here Bishop g6 was
winning would even understand why I
Quincy three ok known while said winning
you decide you three IITs got that shine
oh my god nice geometry ok can I was
just now white white is completely
winning this is again winning check and
steady engage Messiahship yeah I was
just a really bad game but yeah you
cannot have hair from yeah great games
all the time sometimes it's just a
scramble ok thanks for watching